[Musik]
die ecotel de lausanne gehört zu den
renommiertesten handels schulen für die
hotelindustrie 2800 studenten aus über
110 nationen streben an der ehl nach
exzellenz können uns selbstbewusstsein
wir begleiten drei studenten im
vorbereitungsjahr und zwei am ende ihres
studiums
[Musik]
alexandre 18 jahre alt mit seiner matura
in der tasche geht er in das
vorbereitungsjahr immer pc ist 21 sie
wurde in der genferseeregion geboren und
beginnt ein studium an dieser
internationalen schule genau wie
alexander die 19 jahre alt der sohn
eines hoteliers geht mit selbstvertrauen
ins erste semester annina von
falkenstein mit 21 beginnt sie ihre
vorletzte studienjahr
die junge bärin strebt nach nichts
weniger als exzellenz auf rebecca 27
startet sein letztes semester der
energetische afr möchte selbständiger
unternehmer werden
[Musik]
letztes mal in der hotelfachschule
alexandras verhalten ist nicht
angemessen
leider sind ihre noten tief weil ihr
verhalten den werten der schule
überhaupt nicht entspricht
was ist denn mit einer tür passiert
come rain war genervt und hab ein
bisschen dampf abgelassen
aber in der praxis gibt es sich mühe die
day für afr ihm und sein team
sie stellen ihr diplom projekten kunden
unter jury vor sie haben mit erfolg
bestanden
vier erfolgreiche schuljahre das wird
mit der familie und mit würde gefeiert
[Applaus]
annina ist weit weg vom ball in budapest
vor vier tagen habe ich meine letzten
prüfungen geschrieben
ich denke es ist eher gut gelaufen
[Musik]
kurzer moment der entspannung mit ihrer
kollegin und freundin aber sie sind
nicht als touristen hier sie arbeiten
als hostessen an einer internationalen
konferenz
er tut alles um ihre schulter zu
entlasten ich habe viel physiotherapie
gemacht übungen für die halsmuskeln so
konnte ich meine schulter ein wenig
stabilisieren aber seither habe ich zu
wenig trainiert
alex hat die lange liste der küchen
unfälle noch erweitert passiert so was
oft
[Musik]
am ende des semesters beginnt immer mit
dem gourmet koch workshop
sie freut sich auf den berühmten messer
koffer der allen studierenden übergeben
wird
wir kommen dem semesterende näher bald
beginnt unser praktikum
ich freue mich drauf wir kennen uns
jetzt besser aus in der küche es ist
einfach er sich wieder zu erholen
ich schneide ich auch es ist ziemlich
schwierig man muss die finger richtig
halten
das macht mir angst in der wiege der
single demgemäß alter schule führt alex
mit seinem chef eine generalprobe durch
also das menü sensibilität genau wollen
sie die option mit käse also beim menü
von sybil i tät beginnen wir mit der
vorspeise
was wünschen sie zur vorspeise madame
ich nehme eine entenleber und für den
hauptgang kann ich die entenbrust von
nirvana songs bekommen alles was im menü
sensibilität ist finden sie hier sonst
können wir sagen sie genau das was ich
ihnen vorher gesagt habe
madame es gibt zwei menüs zur auswahl
die man nicht kombinieren kann
ok dann nehme ich das schweinekotelett
gut schweinekotelett hätten sie gerne
käse dazu genau jetzt sind sie der
lieder hätten sie gerne käse nein danke
gut madame und als dessert schaue ich
später ich muss mich noch entscheiden
für ihren komfort empfiehlt ihnen das
team nicht das team 4
wir empfehlen ihnen das dessert schon zu
bestellen
im voraus im vorrat für ihren komfort
für ihren komfort empfehlen wir ihnen
das dessert schon im voraus zu bestellen
genau super also ich nehme das sophie
geht klar ein so fliegt man sagt nicht
geht klar verteilt danke madame und
jetzt wiederholen sie die bestellung die
entenleber für die vorspeise der
schweinekotelett für den hauptgang und
zum dessert noch das soufflé sehr gut
die theorie ist er fertig praxis in zwei
minuten
danke stress bringt nichts wir geben
einfach unser bestes
ich versuche mich an alles zu erinnern
ich konzentriere mich auf den moment
[Musik]
anhänger besucht einen der letzten kurve
ihrer englischsprachigen schule sektion
digitales marketing gibt es leute unter
ihnen die auf sozialen netzwerken
influence dann folgen die influenza das
sind diejenigen die neue trends
verbreiten reisen essen gesundheit und
wellness mode schönheit das sind die
fünf hauptbereiche wenn sie als ein
hotel mit spa fitness center yogastudio
haben sind diese dinge sehr wichtig gute
influenza können das was sie machen auf
spektakuläre weise verfahren aber
vorsicht follower kann man ganz leicht
kaufen ein hotel mit vielen verloren
beeindruckt man denkt dass es gut aber
wenn man auf die fotos klickt sieht man
da gibt es nicht viele likes und kein
echtes engagement das sind keine
influenza sondern leute die nur
profitieren wollen von gratis nächten
[Musik]
das gourmetrestaurant empfängt seine
ersten kunden
machen sie das jetzt so wie sie es
gelernt haben viel glück
[Musik]
große premiere für alex der um jeden
preis seine nervosität verbergen muss
guten tag ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich
mein name ist alexandrow ich komme aus
genf und ich werde sie heute bedienen
lassen sie mich ihnen das menü
präsentieren heute haben wir das menü
renaissance und des menüs am 7
ich lasse sie wählen und komme gleich
wieder das ist gut
achten wir noch auf die feinheiten der
präsentation bitte beachten sie dass sie
nicht alles gleichzeitig machen
sie können nicht erklären während sie
gleichzeitig die menüs austeilen sonst
wird ihnen nicht zugehört wenn wir das
menü zum lesen gegeben wird fokussiere
ich nicht mehr auf das was sie sagen
ohne selbstvertrauen versuchen schnell
stoßzeit hinter den kulissen immer ist
für das anrichten der teller zuständig
[Musik]
noch etwas pfeffer drauf die teller zur
kontrolle rüberschieben
[Musik]
die herde laufen auf hochtouren in der
cafeteria werden sieben verschiedene
gerichte angeboten
täglich neue spezialitäten und es gibt
vier weitere orte für take away
sandwiches salate oder backwaren und das
gourmetlokal
[Musik]
ich möchte danke das tut mir alles sah
mich an und auf die jungen ist auch ein
gewisses marketing wo es betriebe ich
möchte gut finden möchte mir schaffen
und ich gut finde und sind die quote
liegt keine art zu sagen sie wüssten wie
sie ihre twitter arbeiten ist besser als
hotel xy was freistoß sowie
telemarketing perspektive
nachdem mittags ansturm müssten die
küchen gereinigt werden der workshop
nennt sich stur ding und wie läuft's
beim sterling ganz locker manipuliert
ein bisschen die geräte man muss einfach
putzen
dafür braucht eine nicht viel im kopf es
dauert schon ziemlich lange aber die
leute hier sind wenigstens nicht geht
gut mit alex alexander arbeitet sehr gut
super cool
er ist groß und stark
aber alex das hier ist ja noch schmutzig
mehr papier
so macht man das nun glänzt es was für
eine technik nur noch zwei tage dann ist
schluss mit diesen schuhen und hosen
letzte woche gab es schon die koffer ab
und nächste woche servicefall keine
absicht chef arbeiten der kollegen
helfen keine dummheiten alles klar
nicht herumspielen
ich hab's nicht extra gemacht nicht der
extra putz begriffe wenn sie fertig sind
putzen sie die ablage die saucen flecken
ich weiß das hat man mir gestern schon
gesagt ich warte nur noch darauf bis es
endlich fertig ist
ich bin am ende bleiben nur noch fünf
arbeitstage das waren 6 sehr intensive
monate außerhalb der kurse mussten wir
nicht lernen
es gab tage mit elf oder zwölf stunden
arbeit
wir sind alle fix und fertig und freuen
uns auf die professionelle umgebung im
praktikum vor dem großen sprung auf den
arbeitsmarkt kümmert sich ab um seine
studienabschluss reise nach thailand
eine langfristige mission zusammen mit
den anderen mitgliedern des komitees die
sich für dieses abenteuer engagieren
wir arbeiten schon seit einem jahr daran
es ist nicht immer einfach manchmal muss
man rund 200 leute über verschiedene
länder hinweg koordinieren alles ist all
inclusive auch der alkohol
so können die leute trinken waren sie
wollen auch das essen und die
aktivitäten sind all inclusive alle
transporte man geht nach thailand für
1700 franken pro person
das ist wirklich nicht schlecht all
inclusive für zehn tage
das ist ein spezialangebot extra für uns
es gibt es nicht im reisebüro
wir haben einige sponsoren die uns
produkte zugeschickt haben damit wir
kleine tüten machen können wir sind froh
den teilnehmern ein geschenk machen zu
können
heute bereiten wir alles vor presley
sonnencreme für die mädchen auch noch
wasserfesten lippenstift supercool
[Musik]
immer kommt früh morgens in genf an
sie hat einen freien tag bekommen für
vorstellungsgespräche in der hoffnung
das bestmögliche praktikum zu erhalten
ich habe jetzt zwei bewerbungsgespräche
1 in genf von 1 in lausanne für suisse
wein das ist ein neues hotel wie viele
gespräche hast du 52 hatte ich schon ich
bin also nicht mehr ganz so aufgeregt
nicht leicht zu finden denn die
konkurrenz schläft nicht im bus bereitet
sich immer mental vor
ich habe jetzt ein gespräch mit dem
personal dienst und dann mit dem chef
der rezeption der personaldienst wird
mir wahrscheinlich mehr mathematische
und logische fragen stellen
da geht es eher um gedächtnistests
das telefon hat sie auf stumm gestellt
und geht zu ihren potenziellen
zukünftigen arbeitgeber ein interview
dem wir nicht beiwohnen konnten
etwas später am morgen kommt auch
alexandra in genf an
obwohl er sehr spät dran ist um
überhaupt noch ein shop interview zu
bekommen konnte er vom netzwerk seines
vaters profitieren der in der hotelwelt
viel einfluss hat dank ihm hat alexandra
einen termin in einem berühmten genfer
hotel palast bekommen
es ist ein sehr schönes hotel für mich
das schönste in genf ich hoffe ich werde
jemand praktikum absolvieren
ich hoffe dass alles gut läuft ich weiß
nicht was schief gehen könnte
die personalmanagerin caroline bühler
bietet ihm sogar verschiedene
möglichkeiten an
wären sie bereit ein basis praktikum zu
absolvieren
ich weiß nicht ob roomservice ihnen
entspricht würden sie lieber in die
küche ich zeige ihnen das restaurant
hier sind die zwei speisesäle jetzt
zeige ich ihnen die küche damit sie
einen eindruck bekommen
frau bühne bringt alexandra zum leiter
des restaurants ich komme später wieder
in einem anderen großen genfer
etablissement hat auch immer hatte im
personalmanager getroffen
sie haben sich nach meinen erfahrungen
erkundigt warum die ehe warum das
intercontinental dann fragten sie auf
englisch nach meinen stärken
nach meinen arbeitserfahrungen und wie
ich auf gewisse situationen reagieren
würde
es ist sehr gut gelaufen auch wenn es in
genf ist würde ich gerne hier arbeiten
und denn ich könnte viel lernen
hoffnungsvoll kehrt sie nach lausanne
zurück zu ihrem zweiten treffen des
tages nun ist alexandra an der reihe
sein bestes zu zeigen
mit seinem gewohnten auftreten wird er
mister perfect spielen in aller demut
aber unter allen umständen selbst sicher
hatten sie jemals in ihrer karriere
probleme mit regeln
generell mit regeln nein
hatten sie jemals probleme mit der
equipe mit der equipe nie was ist ihr
lieblingswein
ich bin kein großer weintrinker kein
kenner am liebsten trinke ich weißwein
stilrichtung
das kann ich nicht sagen
käse keine ahnung dass es nicht mein
gebiet haben sie unser menü gelesen nein
weil ich nicht wusste welche stellung
ich bekomme es ist super gelaufen ich
habe eine klare jobbeschreibung erhalten
das hat mich überzeugt ich hoffe ich
kann hier mein praktikum machen
die aussicht ist wunderschön die berge
der see und die genfer fontaine
[Musik]
auf afrim und die 200 absolventen warten
ganz andere aussichten landung auf der
all inclusive insel machen wir ein
rennen nach monatelanger vorbereitung
und stundenlangem reisen ist es nun an
der zeit zu prüfen ob coconut island
ihre erwartungen erfüllt
das sieht super aus schaute die aussicht
an
ich hoffe das becken hatte 28 grad sonst
gibt's ärger
[Musik]
an ihn als vater besucht seine tochter
dhl ist eine management schule hat
annina auch punkte kochen etwas
dazugelernt
also muss ich mich damit aber man ist
erstmal dank der epoche wo ja abbrennt
ist was man jetzt wieder nicht
eigentlich unmöglich weil pulverschnee
sind brauchen gemacht so richtig fertig
ist als 0 im kochen an die schulter und
hdr wird doch durch das sich
koordinations technisch nicht völlig
unbegabt das ganze schmerzen und so
eigentlich ohne namhafte finger verlust
aber mit annina ist ambitioniert ihr
ziel ein abschluss mit haiders eine
ehren erwähnung ablaufe druck kann ich
auch keinen druck berichtet ist immer
mehr selber aber darum ich jetzt mal
hoch und glück wie noch nie
tatsächlich wies annina die bestnoten
erreichen
[Musik]
letzter tag des semesters immer hat
gerade erfahren dass sie in genf ein
praktikum bekommt nächste woche beginne
ich mein praktikum
ich freue mich das wird eine tolle
erfahrung die sechs monate schule waren
super ich bin ein wenig traurig
aufzuhören
aber ich freue mich auf das neue letzte
unbekannte die resultate ihrer prüfung
ich hoffe ich habe alle bestanden man
weiß es nie denn die sozialkompetenz
noten sind schwierig einzuschätzen aber
im großen und ganzen habe ich nur
positive rückmeldungen erhalten gut denn
die nachprüfungen posten ja zusätzlich
300 franken
und wenn du fehlst verlierst du noch
punkte außer man hat eine ärztliche
entschuldigung 300 für alle prüfungen
300 pro prüfung auch alexandra zählt die
tage wie erwartet hat er sein praktikum
in genf bekommen ich beginne das
praktikum im märz denn sie können mich
jetzt noch nicht beschäftigen
die saison hat noch nicht begonnen und
sie brauchen auch keinen zusätzlichen
mitarbeitern und 4 uhr gibt es eine
abschiedszeremonie adieu
vorbereitungsjahr eine erlösung für mich
ich warte schon lange darauf gehen zu
können
die schule ist fast leer weil alle
bachelorstudenten ihr semester bereits
beendet haben
alex wartet auf die abschlusszeremonie
und entdeckt wie flüchtig seine finanzen
sind
ich habe das gefühl dass mir ein paar
franken fehlen ist aber nicht schlimm
danke
ich denke gerade ich habe heute mittag
noch 100 franken gehabt
hallo mam
könntest du mir mein taschengeld
überweisen
ich bin erstaunt ich wusste nicht dass
ich so wenig geld auf meinem konto habe
meine mutter haben jetzt zwar geld
gegeben um es auf meine karte zu laden
aber das beunruhigt mich jetzt ein wenig
20 franken pro mahlzeit sprich 40 pro
tag sind dann 200 pro woche das tut weh
ich musste meinen lebensstil ändern
am anfang findet man es super trenk noch
ein smoothie oder so aber nun ist
schluss damit
auch er hat ein praktikum in einem
renommierten hotel in genf ergattert
serviere dort dann im café
ich muss anfangen die karte zu lesen
gut wenn ich schon ein bisschen bescheid
weiß am anfang habe ich drei tage
ausbildung weißt du was du verdienst
2179 brutto pro monat
ganz okay ich kann er zu hause schlafen
und alles für mich behalten
ich werde mir einen auspuff kaufen das
wird richtig flutschen
es läuft aber nicht überall wie
geschmiert monika ist für das
vorbereitungsjahr verantwortlich und
weiß das beste in der schweiz verdienen
die schüler fehlen in frankreich zb
verdienen praktikanten rund 440 euro pro
monat
davon kann man in paris zum beispiel
nicht leben
aber hier in der schweiz verdiene die
praktikantin im gastgewerbe und in der
hotellerie gemäss gesetz etwa 2200
franken im monat
und wenn man noch bei den eltern lebt
ist das ein guter lohn für 18 jährige
junge leute
[Musik]
operation umzug für emma sie muss sechs
monate ihres lebens einpacken
wie ist es für dich dein zimmer zu
verlassen
ich hatte glück mit meiner
zimmerkollegin es ist traurig ich werde
meine freundin vermissen während diesen
sechs monaten hier bist du den ganzen
tag mit anderen leuten zusammen und
abends im zweier zimmer
es wird sicher gut tun auch mal ein
bisschen privatsphäre zu haben
trotzdem werde ich dieses zimmer
vermissen der campus kocht die schüler
haben bis zum nächsten tag nur acht
stunden zeit um ihre zimmer zu räumen
ich habe alles der messer koffer den
nehme ich mit so viel wie diese schule
kostet sicher nämlich denn mit hast du
zu hause wieder mehr privatsphäre ja ich
vermisse mein zuhause mein doppelbett
der luxus eines doppelbett ein eigenes
bad
all das gibt es hier nicht
zeit für einen apero das semesterende
der studierenden im vorbereitungsjahr
die stunde des großen auseinander gehen
alle brechen auf ins praktikum einige
ans andere ende der welt und alle
treffen sich für die auszeichnung der
besten ecke des teams das sich in allen
bereichen am besten verhalten hat man
sagt das vorbereitungsjahr sei leicht
war es leicht ja ja das lehrpersonal hat
ein herausragendes team erkoren
ich verkünde es auf französisch weil es
aus der französischen sektion kommt
[Applaus]
wir gratulieren dem team
auf im us team wartet ein vip bereich
hier fließt der champagner in strömen
[Musik]
letzte momente letzte abschiede
sie werden sich lange nicht wiedersehen
und in diesen ersten sechs monaten haben
sie freundschaften geschmiedet
einige brechen bereits zu fernen
horizont auf andere wählen die nähe der
zwillingsbruder von alex kommt um ihn
abzuholen ihn und seinen mitbewohner das
nimmst du mit wir sind noch nicht fertig
ich habe noch zwei voller abfall schau
mal das ist loris mein zwillingsbruder
wie viele gibt von euch wo ihre tochter
wieder zu sehen
klar doch abreise zu ihrem praktikum im
interkontinental sind sie stolz ja sehr
stolz dass sie es geschafft hat
ich bin mir noch nicht hundertprozentig
sicher nicht erhalte meine resultate
erst am 14
bist du optimistisch
[Musik]
annina und ihre gruppe müssen dass
studenten business projekt vorbereiten
ein konzept für eine schweizer grossbank
ihre aufgabe kommerzielle lösungen zu
finden um junge menschen anzulocken
mobile banking einfaches banking
sympathisches banking ein umfangreiches
programm
ein glücksfall für dieses unternehmen
das die studenten voller feuer sind sie
haben einen vertrag mit der schule und
bezahlen dafür zehntausend franken
und der bekommt nichts wenn das
umgesetzt wird
nein nur den ruhm oder auch nicht ihre
erste kundenpräsentation ist für den
folgenden montag geplant und wer wird
verantwortlich sein für die präsentation
der gruppe es muss eine person sein die
keine angst davor hat den kunden
gefallen zu wollen ihnen zu zeigen dass
alles gut läuft dass wir die situation
vollkommen unter kontrolle haben
vielleicht bin ich diese person
[Musik]
in phuket gehen auf rehm und seine
absolventen gruppe auf den markt
[Musik]
wir sind hier auf dem parkett teilmarkt
es ist der größte markt in phuket um
sich den ganzen markt reinzuziehen
braucht man locker drei vier stunden
es ist sehr cool es war mein
lieblingsort als ich hier ein praktikum
macht
das sind ja kakerlaken
schmeckt gut
das kenne ich schon schmeckt wie chips
super gut
[Musik]
natürlich dass
am vorabend seines praktikums verbrachte
alexandra die erste nacht in dem zimmer
das ihm sein arbeitgeber zur verfügung
stellt aber er ist gar nicht zufrieden
damit
ich kann in diesem loch nicht weiter
bleiben
ich suche mir jetzt ein rbi schnell weg
es ist schlecht fixiert es bewegt sich
enorm und die kälte kommt rein
das zimmer gefällt mir nicht das bett
ist zu klein für mich und ich mag den
teppich nicht
es ist hässlich ich habe keinen schrank
wenn ich entscheiden müsste zwischen
diesen zimmer oder dem vom campus würde
ich ohne zu zögern das vom campus wählen
auch wenn es klein war
wenigstens war das bett okay das
badezimmer war auch besser und er ist
kein fan des quartiers in dem er wohnt
das partie viertel man liebt es oder
hasst es
ich mag auch diesen ort hier nicht schon
so einiges schlechtes von meinen
freunden gehört was diese gegen
anbelangt ich will hier nicht länger
bleiben
heute beginnt man praktikum und ich weiß
noch nicht was ich zu tun haben werde
ich werde jemanden vom personaldienst
treffen dann werden wir sehen
vielleicht werde ich heute abend schon
servieren auch alex beginnt sein
praktikum am kreideberg und da er sein
interview per video-konferenz geführt
hat erkundet er zum ersten mal seine
umgebung sehr hübsch mein
bewerbungsgespräch hatte über skype
stattgefunden
ich war soeben in meiner housekeeping
schicht fertig war noch im t shirt als
ich eine nachricht bekam sie fragten
mich ob ich zeit hätte ich sagte ja ich
sei noch im t shirt das sei egal
deshalb war ich noch nie hier aber ich
hatte ihnen gesagt dass ich hätte kommen
können
er trifft an diesem einführungstag alle
anderen neuen praktikanten
ich freue mich sie heute in unserer
firma zu begrüßen
ich weiß dass sie alle ein praktikum
machen das heißt sie studieren hier in
der schweiz
wir haben leute von die jung und von der
high noon zur geschichte des hotels
wir haben das erste ausländische hotel
in japan eröffnet die erste
eisenbahnlinie in china gebaut und die
erste einheimische investmentbank in
hongkong eröffnet alexandra holt seine
uniform ab im bauch seines hotel
palastes
ich hole meine uniform ich arbeite hier
haben sie schon eine nummer
nein überhaupt nicht das ist mein erster
tag alexander genau dass ihr unternehmen
ich habe nur ein hemd zum bügeln
in reglement konformer weste und
krawatte trifft er die mitglieder seines
teams für die mahlzeit vor dienstbeginn
alex und seine praktikums kollegen
machen ein puzzle um die fassaden der
hotels der weltweiten kette
kennenzulernen
das soll den teamgeist fördern ist das
nicht in münchen
ich habe gedacht dass eine brasserie das
ist meine augen ich habe es nicht
erkannt dann folgt die besichtigung der
zimmer etwa 40 quadratmeter
jedes zimmer ist gleich dekoriert nur im
sechsten stock ist es etwas anders das
zeige ich ihnen später ich hatte lust
mich hierhin zu legen
[Musik]
sprung ins kalte wasser für alexandra er
macht sich bereits seinen ersten dienst
anzutreten begrüßte alex an unseren
neuen praktikanten können sie sich kurz
vorstellen tag an alle denn alexander
ein vater ist hotelier daher kenne ich
das internationale milieu ich habe in
zwölf verschiedenen ländern und elf
jahre in paris gelebt bevor ich in die
schweiz kam
ich habe einige praktika in meines
vaters alter hotelkette gemacht ich war
einige mal in paris im service ich bin
jetzt an der ehl und absolvieren ein
praktikum bei ihnen heute abend werdet
ihr in zweierteams arbeiten also kein
stress wir werden noch informiert habt
ihr noch weitere fragen
für mich ist alles gut
die teller polieren sie mit essig das
entfernt die flecken seine erfahrener
praktikanten kollege erklärt ihm die
vorbereiten der aufgabe des abends dafür
zu sorgen dass die teller tadellos sind
so macht man das
es muss alles sauber sein
ich mag die atmosphäre in diesem
restaurant das team ist super und sie
verstehen spaß
das ist genau was ich mag lachen zu
können wären pausen
trotzdem sind alle fokussiert und
arbeiten gut das mag ich wenn die
desserts kommen kann ich sie direkt
servieren
das ist für tisch nummer eins ja du
kannst gehen
[Musik]
das ende naht
es wird sicher schwierig ich weiß nicht
ob ich es schaffen werde nicht zu weinen
aber ja wir werden sehen das macht mich
schon traurig die ehl das ist wie eine
kolonie für vier jahren vielleicht werde
ich einige leute fünf oder zehn jahre
lang nicht mehr sehen
aber ich weiß dass die beziehungen die
man an der ehl knüpft freundschaften
fürs leben sind
was gibt es schöneres um sich zu
verabschieden als die von moon party
bevor man auf den harten boden der
realität zurückkehrt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ihr diplom mit ihren erwähnung im visier
präsentiert annina mit ihrem team am
heutigen vormittag die letzte version
ihrer projektarbeit am zürcher hauptsitz
der grossbank präsentieren
wenn ihre recherchen bestätigt werden
können sie das endgültige konzept
entwickeln
vor der strategie die vision der bank
präsentieren sie ihre ideen um junge
kundschaft anzuziehen
als erstes möchten die mit ihnen über
die notwendigkeit sprechen junge leute
über das thema finanzen aufzuklären
dann würden wir gerne eine reihe von
möglichkeiten vorstellen
wir würden gerne die praktische
umsetzung mit ihnen diskutieren und ihre
meinung dazu hören viele junge leute
wählen das paket der kantonalbank weil
sie mit der nachtschwärmer aktion gratis
die uv benutzen können
wenn sie also dieser junge kundschaft
eine hauptattraktion anbieten steigt die
chance dass sie bei der bank bleibt sie
überzeugen so sehr dass sie zu ihrer
überraschung eingeladen werden ihre
arbeit sogar der direktion der grossbank
vorzustellen ich bin wie gesagt extrem
positiv überrascht wie weit wir bislang
schon gekommen sind
wir haben heute so ein super job gemacht
ja wie sie auch als team zusammen
gearbeitet haben die qualität ihrer
präsentation ja also das ist auf einem
standard da kann sich auch manche
unternehmensberatung noch eine scheibe
von abschneiden
und insofern glaube ich ist es dennoch
angemessen dass ihre ergebnisse
präsentieren sollen annina freut sich
auf ihre weise
und man kommt als gedacht mit irgendwie
der präsentations erfahrung aber wie es
präsentiert bevor meine klassenzimmer
wird heftigst die andere hälfte auf
facebook ist und der lehrer findet so
ein paar notizen das ganze andere rahmen
einer expertise dahinter stecken könnte
sich anhänger nach der schule auch eine
karriere außerhalb des hotel milieus
vorstellen zb im finanzwesen
im bankbereich erst vieles weit mehr
momentan wird der pc ganz die menschen
merken dass ganze zwischenmenschlicher
in hotels der stadt ist praktisch und
ein großer grund wieso ich dort einfach
stehenlassen bescheidet der menschen
kontakt zu werfen
[Musik]
adieu taumel in thailand wo edelkarossen
abfahrt am autosalon kann ich ihnen
behilflich sein
danke wir haben alle nötigen
informationen auf dem tablett wunderbar
sonst fragen sie einfach ich bin gerade
von thailand zurück gekommen es ist
schwierig in thailand war sehr heiß und
hier ist es sehr kalt
der unterschied ist enorm momentan mache
ich diesen job da ich für den märz noch
keinen hatte ich dachte es wäre
interessant ein bisschen hier zu
arbeiten um aktiv zu bleiben
geld zu verdienen meine rechnungen zu
bezahlen das ist wichtig bist du zum
ersten mal hier und auch zum letzten mal
ich hoffe einen job zu finden
momentan bin ich noch auf der suche aber
eher passiv ich habe soeben die schule
abgeschlossen
ich denke ich werde im april voll auf
jobsuche gehen und bewerbungen schreiben
ich mache mir keine großen sorgen
nächstes mal in der hotelfachschule ich
arbeite sieben stunden länger als im
schweizer praktika ich musste sogar ein
ärztliches zeugnis abgeben für zwei
stunden absenz das ist nicht korrekt
es ist echt beschissen alle meine
freunde sind draußen während ich arbeite
es tut wirklich wie im herzen
[Musik]
da stehen noch viele ausländer in ein
paar minuten sind sie alle schweizer das
ist die letzte chance
ich gelobe es
wenn ich auch nur eine prüfung versorger
muss ich sie im februar nachholen und
bin nicht mehr mit meinem kumpel
zusammen
[Musik]